i've had parkinson's for 30 years i mean
i'm scared
supposedly i've said this only than
you've been alive
it's struggle sometimes i mean i'm lying
sometimes it's really hard it's hard to
get up and get ready and get out in the
world what gets you through those days
it doesn't suck uh i'll be it's just
just
an understanding that we'll get through
it yeah that i mean any moment you get
to either well i have a choice i cannot
get through this moment i get through
this moment
michael was diagnosed with parkinson's
in 1991 but revealed the news seven
years later after basically being
bullied the paparazzi they stand up in
my my apartment and heckle at me like
what's the matter with you
and i said i can't just keep going i
can't let my neighbors deal with this
now so i um what it came out and it was
great it was great uh it surprised me
that people responded with an interest
in and and the desire to find an answer
to
the disease and then i i thought they
said that it was a great opportunity i
don't even get put in this position
to to squander it
[Music]
since then the data 4 has raised over a
billion yes billion dollars for
parkinson's research this saturday marks
the 20th anniversary of his annual a
funny thing happened on the way to cure
parkinson's gala where brad paisley and
sting will perform as always dennis
leary will host and michael's wife tracy
paulin will be at his side the couple's
been married for 33 years she's great
she's my best friend and
she's so sexy as hell and
she's great
[Music]